so i mentioned earlier this week that
there's something
uh palpable in the air that feels
different since joe biden won the
presidential election even though joe
biden is not yet the president
just something feels like we're starting
to have a shot
at no longer being a laughingstock
globally and
getting back on a better path and it's
sort of a vague thing
but there's something not vague that is
very quickly changing which is that the
world is starting to ignore donald trump
there's still months until joe biden is
actually inaugurated as president of the
united states and even though
donald trump has refused to concede the
election and is talking about
legal fights and lawsuits and he really
won and all of this stuff
um the world is already dealing with joe
biden
as the adult in the room and is starting
to just ignore donald trump and it is
extremely triggering for donald trump
the biden transition team
is moving along biden launched his own
coronavirus task force
they've already met world leaders are
calling joe biden and talking to him
about the future
boris johnson said he spoke uh to joe
biden and it was
refreshing but on the other side of the
equation
you were seeing donald trump just being
ignored earlier in the week fox news cut
away from his press secretary
kaylee mckennany that was i think monday
for wildly repeating baseless voter
fraud allegations they're just tired of
it
the leaders of major allies like germany
and the united kingdom and israel have
congratulated and welcomed
joe biden joe biden has announced key
appointments and they're being dealt
with by the serious media as
appointments by a president-elect not
some guy
who hasn't really won this uh applies to
the coronavirus task force
joe biden's election yesterday the day
before yesterday of ronald clayne as uh
chief of staff
so this is not the world that trump
wants to be real but it is real
and media outlets are covering it world
leaders are now dealing with biden many
trump staffers are privately saying
the entire contesting the election thing
is pointless
courts have so far found all of donald
trump's various legal challenges to be
completely
spurious and without merit and social
media platforms are also more
aggressively flagging donald trump's
completely unhinged posts as
election-related
misinformation look at newspapers around
the world after reporting the election
results
newspapers have moved on from trump
newspapers around the world are
discussing joe biden's possible cabinet
joe biden's possible foreign policy how
would a joe biden presidency
affect our relationship meaning these
other countries relationships with the
united states
and the contrast is just stunning trump
is tweeting that he won
stuff and suing people while joe biden
announces
policy advisors staffers and more
trump tweets bogus voter fraud
conspiracy theories
meanwhile biden's holding a coronavirus
task force meeting so
let's keep the focus on moving forward
let's not indulge the possibility
that there will be any other outcome but
at the same time let's remember that
there are
what 71 72 million people that voted for
donald trump
many of them like to moonlight as
militia members many could spill out
into the streets if this continues and
what we have to hope for
as trump fires people and has who knows
what up his sleeve if anything
we have to hope that our institutions
are more solid
than uh a few people that trump is
moving around during the transition
and once we get past it we get past it
and it's over
unless trump runs in 2024 but we're not
even dealing with that right now so
again
trump threatening to leave the country
if he loses
saying it's rigged filing lawsuits
firing dissidents or even people not
completely on board with what he says
these are all actions that around the
world we've seen done by some pretty bad
people over the last hundred plus years
uh but in the end trump is going to go
now one other thing
donald trump has not been taken totally
seriously
by the media and leaders of many
countries his entire presidency
folks who never look at foreign coverage
of trump may not know this
but donald trump was not taken seriously
by the newspapers and media outlets
of many countries trump has been ignored
now for years
in many areas climate and others trump
has been one of the least
covered u.s presidents in europe in a
long time because he's been a joke
so for some countries it's not that
they're talking about biden
instead of trump they just weren't
talking about trump
they're going back to talking about an
american president as someone that they
can work with as someone
that they can actually deal with in a
reasonable way that's a very good thing
for the united states
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time
favorite apps called blinkist blinkist
lets you consume an entire book
on your way home from work they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one into text or audio
that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect if you don't have
enough time
to do all the reading you want to do or
if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing i
recently read a brief history of time of
course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
twenty five percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com slash pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video